good morning John it is Tuesday October
7th less than a month away from the
United States official presidential
election do you guys want to hear more
about in Mozilla politics cuz I can
totally talk about Missoula politics you
probably don't actually back when we
were using eventful before they became
our mortal enemy I could see that there
were in fact three nerdfighters in
Missoula Montana yeah well one of them
was me one of them was Katherine
but whoever you are Umizoomi to thank
you so much for existing I think John
forgot to mention in the last video why
we have decided to do Brotherhood 2.1
which is what we're calling it between
the two of us it's not an official name
but this is actually our punishment so
many people love this probably not
everyone does sometimes we ask the
nerdfighters to do amazing unbelievable
things for us and in return they get to
punish us so we recently asked the
nerdfighters if it was possible maybe to
just a little bit ah pone Oprah we
wanted to be more popular than Oprah
that's all we wanted so everyone banded
together and we managed to get more
subscribers on YouTube than Oprah now
that we have done that the nerdfighters
punished us our punishment is to do
Brotherhood 2.0 style vlogging for an
entire month one little piece of
business that I want to take care of
there it's pretty awesome the
nerdfighter named Karen Karen's them
some pretty cool things in the past like
designing that welcome to nerd fight
area shirt that everyone voted on will
probably be one of the shirts on sale at
the tour but she also created this this
is a map of everywhere John and I are
going to be on the New York Fredrik tour
I've taken this map given it a couple of
colors and put it up at Paper Towns calm
so though there is an all-encompassing
map of the nerdfighter tour and you can
click on whatever city you're gonna be
in and it'll take you straight to the
Facebook page you can also click on John
and eyes heads and it will take you to
our Facebook profiles so you can become
our friends getting kind of excited
about the nerdfighter tour pretty
awesome if you aren't signed up on
Facebook this map isn't gonna do you
very much good thinking about putting
together an alternate version with you
know actual text areas for non Facebook
II and nerdfighters I'm not gonna make
anybody sign of her Facebook I was
extraordinarily resistant at first
myself but I do find it quite compelling
now I do
I'm going on I'm a camel so go to
pronounce calm and you will find that
map the last thing on my list that's not
actually a list of things that I'm gonna
talk about the day is this the last good
kiss which John mentioned yesterday in
his video the very day that I finished
reading it that was weird
it was fantastic and if you are over the
age of 17 I strongly suggest you read it
if you're not maybe a little bit dirty
CD a little bit blue a little bit filthy
underbelly of America but you know
that's not for me to choose you ask your
parents if it's okay to read the last
good kiss by James Kremmling who lived
in Missoula and died in Missoula and he
will be missed even though I didn't know
who he was when he died speaking of
dying Carlin and I were driving home
yesterday and Kathryn was like Hank I
think I just saw a dead body and I was
like haha joke joke and she was like no
we turn the car on we went by again and
I was like holy parked the car got out
of the car it was like a fenced in area
with razor wire over the fence and I
walked up and I just like naked body
with shoes on and nothing else
was freaking out and I have the phone
and I was opening the phone and I look
and it is a freaking mannequin why did
somebody put a naked mannequin with
shoes on like it fell off the razor wire
fence and died in the contorted mass of
body parts you know that there's a thing
that looks a lot like a dead body
sitting out in the public view of your
weird-ass razor wired lot oh yes yes we
do that just to freak you out I'm glad
we've got you ha ha
practical joke ha ha ha I don't know why
the razor wire fence owning freaky
mozillian has a British accent but he
does anyway that totally sucks but I
think that we will recover and John I
will see you tomorrow